well let's go live now to Lebanon where
the newly chosen Prime Minister Hassan
diab is speaking that Tiffany do you
believe that you are able to meet the
people's demand and take the people out
of this crisis people are not to blame
this is what we have come to and it is
no surprise that the people have come to
this point people have been suffering
for long that is true we will consider
the necessary procedures and necessary
financial measures in order to exit this
crisis however I request you to give me
time you are to give me some time well
you've been watching the new prime
minister of Lebanon that's Hassan Diab
he was addressing the nation there live
on Lebanese television well he was just
appointed by the president Michelle
Allen after consultations today with
Michelle Allen's deputies there has been
a large amount of consternation about
his appointment as the new prime
minister he was nominated by the
Hezbollah alliance and this comes after
months of political stalemate
you'll recall that back in October large
amounts of Lebanese came out onto the
streets and demonstrated in cities
across the country
after that Saad Hariri the prime
minister the Sunni prime minister
resigned he was then the caretaker Prime
Minister that refused to take office
again resulting in a political stalemate
that has ended only now well for more on
this let's bring in our correspondent
Tony Berkley who is live for us in
Beirut Tony we were talking about the
consternation at at Hassan D herbs
appointment earlier but what's the
what's the political sense there now
what kind of reaction are we seeing
well at the moment he's just given an
impromptu press conference just behind
me and he said some very emotive things
he said that he was going to try and
form a government as soon as possible
he's going to be talking in the coming
hours and days with former heads of
government for all political parties and
also from representatives of those civil
societies that were leading the
demonstrations for the last two months
calling for a complete overhaul
he actually said I hear I've heard your
calls for the last two months I've felt
your pain and heard your words and
demands so he wants to talk to them he
called out to the entire country to give
him a chance to form a government and
make this work he said saving the
country should be a priority and he
wants everybody to join hands to try and
make that happen now as you will know he
was nominated predominantly by the pro
Hezbollah a mile alliance the sunny
bloc's walked away they didn't make a
nomination for whatever reason we're
trying to read into why they didn't do
that but people are saying that he was a
hezbollah man he is saying quite clearly
tonight that he is an independent
candidate and he will work for the
benefit of Lebanon that will have to be
remain to be seen how that translates to
the people on the streets to be
demonstrating and calling for an
overhaul remains to be seen I want to
ask you more about that Tony because we
have seen a huge amount of anger on the
streets at the overall political
establishment how do how do protesters
in the street view Hassan dia what kind
of a man do they think he is
well he's been a former government
minister he served in the government we
2011-2014 we've actually seen messages
on social media today when his
nominations were coming through that
maybe there was not everything that was
100% good about the man that there was
made corruption allegations none of this
has been corroborated but it's it's
interesting to know that his prime
minister at the time
mr. Najib Mikati that was one of the
people in this sunny block that did not
nominate him and he hired him in 2011 I
think there's going to be a lot of mixed
reactions to this but as the man says
give me a chart he represents an old
establishment at the moment the people
want him to represent a new
establishment they want a techno cracked
critique government they want new
representatives new analysts they don't
this techno political government that's
ruled this country for thirty years
through nepotism through corruption and
it's led this country to the brink of
economic collapse so they want to see a
big change now he's got a big job on his
hands to make that change happening
before he can head a government he's got
to do a lot of talking a lot of horse
trading and of course you've got this
big large sunny block that's been
involved in the government since 2011
they have got a big say in this so he's
got to do some deals and people are
hoping that it will work but we'll see
tonight on the streets we'll see over
the weekend how they react to his
nomination and his words Tony we were
talking earlier about LeBrons very long
history of foreign powers getting
involved in regional politics there and
I'm wondering how his appointment is
going to be regarded by external forces
beyond the borders of Lebanon
well that's always been a continuing
factor in Lebanon because ever since you
know I've been reporting Lebanon outside
powers of play in fighting their battles
on the soil here according to the
Lebanese I've been speaking to though
the outside powers especially the US say
it's about policy not personality they
want to see a government that represents
people that is stable that can bring
prosperity back to the country so that's
what they're saying actually in in
public what they're saying in private I
don't know because there's lots of
issues at stake here you've got Syria on
the body
let them you've got Israel at the
southern border there's issues going on
there you've got a ran in the back of
the seat Hezbollah it is here it's very
strong so what is going to happen how
will people going to react are they
going to become more Lepidus are they
become more international we'll have to
see
and we will continue watching very
closely Tony Bradley there for us live
in Beirut thank you Tony